let's uh let's take this story about joe
rogan's passive comment and turn it into
a major news cycle event i suppose that
seems to be what everyone does but i
want to talk about censorship i want to
talk about what's happening with uh with
big media with youtube with cnn and i do
think it's worth launching off with this
so here's the story from dailymail joe
rogan threatens to quit his 200 million
dollar spotify deal if he has to walk on
eggshells and mind my p's and q's
following n word and vaccine
misinformation controversies
they say on on the uh journal experience
guess an mma fighter josh barrett 44
said he was worried he'd be judged for
every little thing quote
i will quit if it gets to a point that i
can't do it anymore where i have to do
it in some sort of weird way where i
walk on eggshells broken replied he has
been under fire in recent months this we
understand and now he's basically come
out and and made this statement joe also
came out and talked about chris rock
getting slapped in the face because i
think as a comedian everyone's like yo
that was not cool to smack chris rock
but we'll get into that stuff later
i want to point out first and foremost
as i said
is this just a passive comment you know
he's sitting there he's he's doing a
show and he's like i'd quit if it got to
that point because i i just want to
mention hasn't it got to that point
how many episodes now have been taken
down to the joe rogan experience do we
know how do you countless what's that
website do you know what that website is
i don't know what it is
jremising.com ridiculous let me see if i
can find it jremissing.com yeah
jerrymissing.com there you go 113
episodes of the of the joe rogan podcast
are missing from spotify and on february
4th 2022 a whole bunch of episodes were
taken down including one with kyle
kalinski where kyle so everyone said the
reason they were taken down is because
they're episodes where joe said the
n-word
kyle said that wasn't true right and he
was that he said in that episode though
he was talking about saudi arabia and
that's what he thinks so i i just gotta
i just gotta you know call it like it is
man i think joe's a good dude i think he
does tremendous good but i'm also not
convinced he would quit i think that if
it really did came down to it joe would
not publicly say hey i'm being forced to
do something where was joe rogan's
statement on why magic news's episode
was withheld for three weeks
i think it was three weeks magic was
lighting up the internet on this this
magic hosts uh you know previously and
recently hosted a huge show on the radio
in london what is it um
what what's lbc stand for one it's not
no it's not london company
british channel or something no it's not
that it was like conversation
something like that i don't know it's
biggest conversation london broadcasting
company originally no no that's not what
it stands for that's what this says it's
a radio show it means something else
because i said that to him and i was
like what is it like london london
broadcasting corporation he left he's
like no it's like something biggest
conversation
but anyway imaginable is not some random
nobody so when he goes and records with
joe and talks about a whole bunch of
really important stuff and then the
episode doesn't go live for almost a
month and we hear nothing from joe i
gotta be honest as much i think joe is a
good dude and i think he does stand up
for a lot of people in good ways i also
think that if it really came down to it
he would not tell us he's being censored
he'd pull the episodes passively mention
them
you know not really give some some good
answer and then the reality is he'd
likely apologize
well that's my frustration a lot with
you know the totality of hollywood and
entertainment because you know for those
who don't know that that was where i
started you know i directed oscar
winning actors actresses some of the
biggest music stars and
you know being in that world i always
hear now that i'm in politics people go
oh was it really hard being like the
lone conservative and the truth is i was
not the lone person on that side the
reality is there's a bunch of cowards i
was gonna say you're making
conservatives sound like howard's but
you said it before me they're a bunch of
cowards you know and i've said it to
their faces and some of these people are
the biggest stars in the industry
and they're just terrified of not having
easy access to capital it's not just
access it's easy access i could call out
some people right now yep because i
remember i was hanging out in la
and uh there was a bunch of trump
supporters that were uh doing some event
and there was some celebrity they saw
who they knew and they walked up and
they you know high five fist bump gave
hugs and then this this individual just
was like no no no nobody can know nobody
can know he's like i'll lose i'll lose
everything yep yeah yeah yeah
it's it's a big it's a big thing and you
know
that cowardice is gonna cost us
something at some point and that's why i
think you know we've got to try to
motivate these people to show that you
can have success outside of this because
it does have a cultural impact and then
being able to see that you know honestly
even on levels like this that a show
like this can be as successful as it is
i would hope would give some sort of
inspiration to somebody like rogan to
say you know what and he's done this
before before he was with spotify so i
wish it would just sort of encourage
those people to say you know have some
courage go fight for something fight for
free speech fight for these values you
say you believe in because that
episode's incredible by the way you know
he went he went hard
machide how do you say that you imagine
it was one of our it was one of the most
significant rogan episodes ever which is
why i i you know i always want to cut
joe slack he's got the biggest podcast
in the world he does tremendous good he
reaches so many people and i know a ton
of people who are like left-leaning
normies who have learned a lot of truth
and principle because they watch joe
absolutely but i'm going to be honest
when i look at this i can't come out
here in good conscience and be like look
i know joe i consider him a friend and
uh he's he's totally right he'll stand
up i'm like dude everybody knows that
episodes have been pulled everybody
knows that episodes have been withheld
first for or delayed everybody knows
joe's apologized for a variety of things
i think it would be dishonest for for me
to just be like oh yeah yeah he'll
definitely i don't think so man
you tell me if i'm wrong about this i do
feel like if you were in a similar
situation which i don't think you would
be in in the first place because i don't
think you want to be owned by anybody
but if you were in that situation you
would absolutely not stand for it like
if uh uh
so in in in this respect
i i have a different strategy on stuff
like this it would be an insane lie for
me to say that uh if youtube ever came
to me with censorship demands i would
refuse well of course not of course
there's been several circumstances where
i've been like i can't say a certain
name on the show so nobody say it right
so we set up timcast.com to make sure
that we could have our own space that
was isolated and protected that was
fortified
uh
joe's in that space yeah he's he's
literally in his fortified space he's
got a secure contract
and if he's willing to withhold shows on
with a secure contract now that i'm like
i mean
in that circumstance yeah i wouldn't do
it and and i got to say there are some
things i can't talk about because we do
work with other companies but we've
actually had uh people come to us and
try and cancel us you know with with
things we're doing on the website and
we've basically given them the middle
finger and good we we play a similar
game to like what uh what daily wire did
when harry's pulled out and denounced
them they were like we are going to put
everything that we would have we had to
promoting you to denouncing you to
rivaling you to challenging you so i'll
put it this way on youtube there's a
different story here joe i i think he
mentioned this but i could be maybe a
misremember it's been a while you know
you mentioned that like youtube there's
censorship it you know on spotify he's
going to be free it's it's a it's a
network deal and already we're seeing
there's still censorship i do think it's
fair to say that if he stayed on youtube
they would have nuked him in two seconds
for a variety of agreed yes so
you know
what do we do well we we here at temcas
we want to keep the youtube show going
we want to maintain as much reach as
possible for the the maximum good we can
do but we always we always promote the
website we have journalists on the
website and we want to make sure we're
leveraging the access to this you know
to youtube's network to promote a space
where we can have whatever conversation
we want to have if rogan watches he
should think about that those couple
words you used maximum good what is the
maximum good he could do because he he
has a very successful career you know we
actually used to live in the same area
um when we were both in calabasas
and you know he's incredibly successful
at this point what's the maximum good
you can do and it would be build your
own build it and they will come i think
you would have more people
and it'll have some longevity you know
you can bring in other people and then
allow a space where people can be free
yeah you know look uh
when we started expanding
timkastz.com when we started expanding
when i started expanding from just my
youtube show which was me sitting in a
room with a with a gopro pointing at my
face and now we're in this like six
figure studio
i was not rich i i i was like taking all
of the money that i was making and like
spending like crazy to like build and
grow and expand
joe
was rich before the podcast and was rich
during the podcast but this just
it just goes to show there's different
kinds of people and and i'll stress this
again i mean the amount of good the dude
has done yeah for one thing the fact
that i'm even here and the success i've
had is is uh due partly to joe helping
me out i should say you know joe
expressed to me he was like nah look man
you came on my show you helped make
those episodes big and i'm like yeah but
look he didn't have to have me on
there's you know he really really helped
out everything we're doing that's
undeniable and so i think he has helped
create a whole lot through his sphere of
influence
i just get frustrated sometimes when i
see people of massive means not being
like yo if you've got
if you've got 10 million dollars
10
you could be like i'm going to take i'm
going to take a million bucks and i'm
going to start
something seed something seed something
i i think it's fair to point out it
would it's very difficult to launch a
podcasting platform yeah i think joe
could have done it he could a hundred
percent no
no doubt he could when it comes and it
would be massively successful it really
comes down to mental capital i think a
lot about this lately like if because we
talk sometimes like if you had 100
million dollars why don't you do
something with it why don't you create a
company because it is it requires your
time and your energy otherwise unless
you're going to do like we were kind of
chatting about this before the show
you're either throwing your money at a
group of people that you're just going
to trust and hope that it works out but
at that point rogan's not even involved
anymore i don't want to see him throw
money down a drain so like does he have
the time and the energy and the desire
to run a company because that is a lot
of work a lot of listening um
hours and hours
many many days you know every day you
don't work is basically the company's
going to fall apart that you're not
there so yeah
it's i think there's enough people who
believe in him though in the message and
and you know what he's doing where you
could build out a team where that
wouldn't even be necessary i do think
that that's the case you know even even
if you look in that more corporate world
of entertainment there's people dying to
get out of these places if they were
given an opportunity to go run with
something that could be really you know
an open forum for freedom and for people
to do podcasts and similarly sort of
just have no rules it's hard
you know i'll i'll i'll say that it is
not easy
everything we're doing um
you get to the point where
people really need to understand this
about companies once you reach like 50
employees
i say like because it varies from state
but federally a whole bunch of crazy
restrictions and regulations kick in all
of a sudden now you're dealing with uh
infiltrators i'd love to just you know
hire everybody but what happens if you
hire antifa yep what happens if joe's
like i'm gonna launch my own thing and
then you get one person who's like i
only need six months and then i can
plant that seed and nuke everything from
yeah it's difficult yeah and you'll get
people who will do it you'll get people
who act like your best friend and their
only interest is just extracting as much
as they can from the system and watching
it burn down and then they'll spend all
their time just complaining about you
and talking about how you were a bad
person if you did everything for them
it's nightmarish it's the same thing
with campaigns by the way political
campaign same thing i mean you get the
same deal with political infiltrators
wanting to get in things like that so
you have to keep a very tight-knit group
and it's a bummer i wanna i wanna just
kind of uh make sure i stress the point
joe's not obligated to do anything and
at this point he's done so much good
yeah
the the dude could turn his show into a
cooking show and i'd feel like he had a
great run man yep yeah great no
absolutely true but this is the thing
about great people is you expect and
want greatness all the time and you push
them to be the best version of what you
think they can be right and that's a
healthy thing that's what a real friend
does too a real friend doesn't just clap
for you and pretend you're always doing
good a real friend's gonna go
you need to go and try to level up and i
think that's you know at the core of
anybody sort of saying this that
appreciates him is we're saying level up
man you have it in you you can level up
and you can take a stand that is going
to be powerful i also wonder just you
know look obviously we're not afraid of
offending leftists i just don't care and
i wonder if joe's mentality is more so
there are people who are on the left who
just don't know
and you've got to be able to reach them
somehow i can respect that i can respect
that i'm not saying that's exactly what
he's doing but i certainly respect
varying degrees of trying to reach
people
because i'm at the point where it's like
look we're going to talk about the truth
we're going to we're going to we'll
we're typically respectful and the
members only stop by timcast.com i was
swearing a lot yesterday yeah i was
swearing at ron perlman because that
dude is he's crazy crazy i actually
tried to watch that twitter video he
made and i had to shut it off twice out
of fear like he scares me because i've
seen him in so many movies i mean you
can kind of almost see a mug shot in it
you know if you just if you look hard
enough you can see his future mug shot
because something's gonna something's
gonna crack the guy like one eye was
like down why does he do that thing
where he like
he smashes his chin you know what i
instead of filming a video and being
like hey
all of these photos and videos are of
him pointing down it's so weird mashing
his face so he looks crazy and like
donnie boy especially because like as a
director you know
actors like him have been blocked out so
many times where they know the blocking
they know how they look in front of a
camera like he's he's camera aware he
knows what is going on and he does that
intentionally and okay you know the
greatest thing ever would be is if like
ron perlman comes out in like a few
months and then he has a whole
collection of all of the videos and
photos he's posted and then he just
tells everybody he's like i hope i made
you laugh because it was the funniest
thing ever i gotta be honest like
watching that
out of the context of politics is one of
the funniest things ever
he's a meme where people like show a
picture of his face all smashed and like
saying crazy things i mean and it's also
like it's just an extension of the
craziness of the left right now where
literally all of them have to make sure
they go gay
gay
gay
as if all of us are like
call the police
this person just said the word again
this this is illegal now
it's like the bill doesn't stop it from
happening ridiculous thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you